lancement de la fusée artemis a été
reporté à nouveau à une date ultérieure
c'est prévu à 14h17 on avait une fenêtre
de deux heures ça allait bien parce que
la météo collaborer on avait 80% de
chances de lancement sauf qu'un problème
qui est survenu au niveau de
l'alimentation en carburant une fuite on
semble pas avoir été en mesure de
colmater le tout lundi ou s'il lancement
avait été reporté pour des problèmes
techniques
alors nous ça nous semble un coup dur
pour le système pour le programme
spatial américain dont on est en train
de travailler sur le retour vraiment de
l'être humain sur la lune 50 ans après
l'avoir quittée mais ce n'était pas un
vol habité aujourd'hui faut le
mentionner ça devait quand même être une
étape assez importante avec ce lancement
dans ce programme spatial alors avec
nous pour bien comprendre ce qui s'est
passé ce qui va s'en venir vous allez
reconnaître l'astronaute david saint
jacques
l'animateur de découverte charles
tisseyre également robert lamontagne
astrophysicien à l'université de
montréal merci messieurs d'être avec
nous cet après midi on avait prévu faire
une émission spéciale à cette heure-ci à
14 heures parce que dans 17 minutes en
principe on devait avoir un an cement
malheureusement c'est pas le cas on va
essayer de comprendre ce qui s'est passé
monsieur saint-jacques j'ai envie de
vous demander tout de suite votre
réaction parce que nous on a été très
déçu et on se demande si c'est pas deux
pas en arrière le combien de fois
tout est vrai que si comme de réaction à
moi là c'est un peu comme monsieur jack
le petit garçon excité comme tout le
monde est déçu alors non la plus grosse
fusée jamais construite c'était au tour
de cap canaveral décevant mais
l'ingénieur en moi se dit
il y avait un problème ça valait la
peine de s'arrêter on n'est pas de
raison de partir aujourd'hui il faut pas
succomber à l'excitation au désir de
partir freddy c'est un lancement d'essai
ce un pull le vol de certification du
lanceur un des attentes techniques
extrêmement élevé plus élevé que
lorsqu'il sera certifié parce que c'est
la première fois que la fusée la capsule
cette rampe de lancement à nice systems
et et les systèmes de navigation que
tout ça est utilisée ensemble pour la
première fois fait que le sait qu'on est
comme si on aime on fait ces vols
d'essai là en public comme ça mais il ya
aucune attente que ça parte comme nous
ce qu'on veut c'est que ça marche sur le
moment on dit qu dos c'est parce que ça
va marcher aucune attaque mais avait
beaucoup de pression et on va y revenir
charles beaucoup de pression sur les
gens de la nasa mais tout d'abord
monsieur la montagne pouvez vous nous
expliquer ce qui s'est passé pourquoi ce
décollage la pop au lieu on parle de
problèmes au niveau de l'alimentation en
carburant c'est pas rien quand même
oui bon fait le carburant principal de
ce type de fusée c'est un mélange
d'oxygène et d'hydrogène et donc comme
on doit les liquéfié à très basse
température
on procède au remplissage
quasiment à la dernière minute sinon une
bonne partie du carburant s'évaporerait
et donc on avait rempli l'oxygène on est
en train de remplir le réservoir
d'hydrogène et campsas combinant
ensemble ça fait une réaction chimique
en suisse a produit de l'eau mais ça
dégage beaucoup d'énergie ce qui peut
propulser les fusées donc au moment du
remplissage du réservoir d'hydrogène il
y avait une fuite au niveau d'une valse
anciennement un joint d'étanchéité et on
n'arrivait pas à remplir qu'il fallait
pas le maté la fuite ils ont fait
quelques tentatives
avant le lancement pour il ya quelques
trucs qui peuvent être utilisés le port
tenté de contourner le problème est de
toute évidence ça n'a pas fonctionné et
donc vaut mieux régler le problème de la
fuite est reporté le lancement en
principe dans deux jours on parle de
lundi en fin d'après midi on va
poursuivre les discussions avec vous
monsieur la montagne parce qu'en ce
moment se dit on est entraînés de régler
un petit pépin technique parce que nos
invités studio vous entendez pas bien
mais est-ce qu'on peut parler d'une
technologie qui est fiable est ce qu'on
peut se poser la question
oui c'est une technologie qui est fiable
et éprouvée depuis des dizaines d'années
mais évidemment et david saint-jacques
le souligner il le souligner à plusieurs
reprises c'est une machine extrêmement
complexe beaucoup
d'éléments techniques doivent
fonctionner simultanément et donc il
vaut mieux s'assurer de que ça
fonctionne ça a l'air assez banal parce
que bon on pense au report de lundi
dernier où il y avait entre autres sur
ce problème de fuite soit un problème de
capteur on a l'impression de décrire des
problèmes d'une voiture n'est ce pas que
ça sente mais ce sont des problèmes
techniques qui sont cruciaux et aidé
avait de bien fait de souligner c'est un
texte ils font que tout fonctionne parce
que la prochaine étape c'est avec un
équipage donc de vrais jumeaux we shall
on parlait d'un monsieur singer que
disait on voulait pas se mettre de
pression on espérait que ça fonctionne
mais en même temps il y en a de la
pression sur la nasa en ce moment là ça
fait 50 ans qu'on n'a pas mis le pied
sur la lune c'est quasi patriotique
aussi le ce qui s'est passé aux états
unis c'est important que cette fusée
fonctionne quand ils vont la faire
partir mais comme david disait pour pas
à faire partir avant qu'elles soient
prêtes et vous il faut savoir que dans
le cadre d'un navette spatiale à de
nombreuses reprises ils ont dû reporter
des lancements pour des fuites
d'hydrogène justement hydrogène est une
molécule très fine la plus petite
molécule elle s'infiltre partout c'est
très difficile d'avoir un joint
d'étanchéité entre le gros tuyau qui
alimente le réservoir d'hydrogène
liquide de la fusée est au fond ce cette
interface il ya un joint d'étanchéité
puisque ces molécules sont tellement
film c'est difficile de bien fermer se
joint la ils ont vraiment essayé mais
est ce qu'ils vont pouvoir repartir
lundi ou mardi
il ça fait cinq six fois qu'ils essayent
qu'il va devoir rentrer au garage
comment
ce qui est en jeu à ce qu'on peut
concevoir de faire la réparation ou le
remplacement sur place pendant que
refuser toute assemblée laprete sur le
pas de tir ou est-ce qu'il faut la
ramener au hangar ce qui était demandé
il ya un risque à faire ça risque à la
déplacer à démonter les pièces à accéder
donc c'est un peu c'est très nasa c'est
ce qu'on appelle l' équilibre des
risques il ya des bénéfices des pour et
des contres l'important où il ya des
pressions politiques de toutes sortes
mais il faut gars c'est une bulle de
calme pour les ingénieurs pour prendre
des décisions rationnelles parce que ce
qu'il faut comme ray charles c'est qu'au
moment où on appuie sur le bouton go ça
marche on est parti à ce moment là et là
c'est une autre formidable aventure qui
attend j'imagine le programme spatial
monsieur la montagne parlez nous un peu
de la suite de ça parce que il ya une
raison bien précise pour laquelle on
veut se rendre sur la lune c'est que ça
va nous servir éventuellement je sais
pas ce qu'on va voir cela dans plusieurs
dizaines d'années peut-être de base de
lancement à une exploration encore plus
lointaine
oui tout à fait alors ce qu'on doit
apprendre à faire tes à vivre dont les
pas de manière autonome si on peut dire
on le fait déjà avec la station spatiale
internationale
mais on est à quelques heures d'un
retour sur terre si jamais il y avait un
pépin et on peut constamment être
ravitaillée lorsqu'il faut apprendre à
faire c'est à vivre un peu plus loin de
la terre mille fois plus loin dans le
code la lune avec une autonomie en plus
grande autonomie et à terme c'est
d'apprendre à
se projeter vers la planète mars donc
l'objectif je dirais ultime c'est
d'envoyer un équipage habités vers mars
qui elle est à peu près 1000 fois plus
loin que nos yeux est donc là il faudra
avoir une autonomie complète donc il
faut apprendre à faire fonctionner des
engins à protéger d
les astronautes
en orbite autour de la terre on est en
bonne partie protégée encore par lebouc
bouclier magnétique de notre planète
mais dès qu'on sort à plus grande
distance on ne l'est plus donc on est
soumis à des problèmes de dire adieu à
sion donc comment se protéger
adéquatement comment vivre dans ces
environnements c'est un peu l'objectif
de la mission est évidemment établir un
camp de base sur la lune ou si on peut
avoir des visées d'exploitation
commerciale des visées scientifiques
aussi sur la lune
monsieur saint jacques ça ressemble à
quoi vivre sur la lune
écoutez
union est présent dans la montagne bien
bien campé le loto pour cette
progression vraiment ambitieuse vers ce
rêve complètement fou de l'eso mars
juste pour donner une image aux
auditeurs le quand on est sur la lune la
terre mais ça ressemble peu à la lune
qu'en vue de la terre un ce groupe sera
vraiment le plus drôle mais c'est de
mémoire de grandeur quand tu es sur mars
la terre salaire d'une étoile d'une
petite étoile bleue que la misère des
troubles en ciel comme la nuit on a de
la misère à trouver mars dans le ciel
catalan sûrement sept sacs la terre
l'air
complètement un moteur de grandeur c'est
comme si depuis vingt et un ans laborde
notre station plan international on
faisait du camping dans la cour arrière
de la maison qui en essayant des
nouvelles technologies un nouvel tantôt
niveau sacs de couchage au niveau
brûlures en effet les affaires hop
toujours entre la maison ça va mal le la
lune c'est comme à lire je sais pas moi
en haut du mont saint guibert
on pourrait venir et on va pouvoir
passer la nuit mais notre ambition c'est
d'aller sur les restes faut être
complètement autonome pour ses mission à
l'opie ça c'est vraiment un aspect qui
est franchement nouveau parce que haddad
dans toute l'histoire du programme
spatial habité on a réussi à faire des
missions en prenant pour acquis le côté
santé de l'équipage allait bien aller
parce qu'ils étaient soit pas très loin
ou partez pas très longtemps mais quand
on envisage des missions pour
s'installer sur l'alluré meilleur les
semences et à simon si un point non
emprunt on traverse un point de
non-retour limitant vers mars et prendra
trois ans
un point non répond il faut qu'il soit
complètement autonome pour la santé et
aussi pour la nourriture faut apprendre
à faire pousser l'europe à partir avec
la pac est barbare sera facile même si
on ne
skie merveilleux c'est que
c'est tous des choses au tombeau
bénéficier sur terre ces avancées l'a1
en amélioration des soins de santé pour
les gens qui habitent en région éloignée
faire pour une rupture des régions
isolées tout ce qu'on apprend comme
d'habitude c'est un peu ça la magie avec
apolo ohno développer l'informatique
moderne
on se parle maintenant à travers des
satellites avec des taux qui n'attendent
pas grâce à apple ou enquête parle c'est
comme si l'ex passe nous fournissait
sans cesse l'excusent pour se creuser la
tête un peu plus fort que de découvertes
à venir charles
ordinaire vous savez la capsule orion
elle même c'est ça qui est passé
fabuleux elle est faite pour aller à la
lune d'abord mais ensuite à la planète
mars elle peut faire partie d'un trait
martien qui se rendraient vers la
planète et donc il doit tester dans des
conditions extrêmes elle va être un
moment de nerfs 450 mille kilomètres de
la terre on sait que apollo xiii a dû
faire le tour de la lune pour revenir en
catastrophe s'est éloigné de la terre à
400 mille kilomètres de la terre mais
cette fois ci c'est un record ces 450
mille kilomètres de la terre est donc
comment la capsule va-t-elle réagir
comment va-t-elle bien pouvoir protéger
les astronautes à l'intérieur la
température la pressurisation
l'irradiation les radiations qui
viennent du soleil mais qui viennent
aussi des autres galaxies des autres
étoiles ce qu'un facteur important n'est
ce pas d'avis effectivement on et aborde
un orbite terrestre on est comme des
personnes en montagne on est protégé par
le champ magnétique de la terre on n'est
qu'à l'intérieur de cette bulle de
protection mais quand on s'éloigne vers
la lune et au-delà on est tous nus
exposé aux radiations donc un risque de
cancer pour parler simplement et on l'a
vu maintenant apollo s'est en partie du
jour c'est une chose mais là à partir
des mois des années
c'est pas clair encore comment on va
faire pour que les astronautes et
survivre qu'un autre problème c'est
revenir sur terre quand on dit qu'on
voit très loin il faut imaginer c'est
que quand on revienne une telle distance
on retombe sur terre d'enfance de très
loin capsule moi je vais vous dire ça
ressemble pas mal à paulo je te promets
ce même jean guy gross n'avait
évidemment ça il ya eu des événements
des épisodes tragiques là dans
l'histoire des navettes mais
le point chargé de cette mission oui
c'est un des points de tester la capsule
orion va revenir sur terre elle va
frapper atmosphère à 11 kilomètres par
seconde
impossible sur terre de reproduire ça
s'est vite et cela avec des gaz avec
déplacement il faut le tester in situ
vous laisser dans l'espace en la lançant
loin derrière la lune et la faisant qui
m'est retombé sur terre de cette
distance incroyable 61 des objectifs
lors de l'émission pour s'assurer que
quand vous décidez de mettre des êtres
humains à bord c'est un marché que le
bouclier thermique qui tout à fait
nouveau qui est plus gros que tout ce
qu'on a connu pour des capsules existe
assez chaleur là comme dit david on n'a
jamais testé encore et dans le cas d'
apollo 8 il se fait pris le risque
d'envoyer des humains autour de la lune
et de la de les ramener dans une capsule
qui avait un bouclier thermique qui
n'avait jamais été testée dans ces
conditions là parce qu'il fallait battre
les russes dans les batteries soviétique
on n'est pas dans le même contexte de
monsieur la montagne j'imagine qu'on
veut prendre aucun risque aussi et c'est
un peu pour cette raison qu'on voit tous
ces reports aussi à à la nasa est ce que
c'est le fruit d'une collaboration de
plusieurs pays ce qu'on voit ce matin
cette mission arte messous et
spécifiquement américain que cette
volonté de vouloir retourner sur la lune
la volonté est certainement je dirais
internationale c'est le rêve la plupart
des jeunes d'explorer l'espace et
d'aller très loin très clairement ici le
maître d'oeuvre c'est l'agencé spatiale
américaine dont la nasa mais il ya des
collaborateurs d'un peu partout dans le
monde le canada david très bien expliqué
et très intimement impliqué il y aura
très certainement un astronaute canadien
lors du prochain vol artemis 2 il y aura
une des composantes de fabriquer au
canada pour la prochaine petite station
orbitale le gateway est en orbite autour
de david donc on fournira entre autres
une autre version du désormais célèbre
rock canadien donc plusieurs pays sont
impliqués les européens les japonais
sont impliqués là-dedans et peut-être
pour revenir un peu sur l'élément de
auquel faisait référence charles on est
confronté à une autre course aussi avec
cette fois ci les chinois qui ne se
cachent pas ils veulent envoyer des
taïkonautes vers la lune pour
probablement la fin de la décennie et je
me souviens que l'ancien président
américain avait
demandé à ce que l'on devance un peu des
chantiers du programme américain
justement pour maintenir cette
prestige national si je peux dire
d'aller sur la lune si je prépare la
participation canadienne corps artemis 2
va s'envoler avec quatre astronautes à
bord il va y avoir un canadien
tennis c'est quand même incroyable de
penser qu'il va voir un compatriote
mais dessus un peu comme la génération
apollo la génération apollo se souvient
[Rires]
du mûrier d'un vide jamas ah ouais y'a
pas un instant tu penses qu'ils seraient
pas attiré par le prospect nissart
mission d'essai plein de risques aussi
mes missions vers la lune on est on est
tous été impressionnés ma génération la
génération apollo par ces images-là de
la terre vue de la lune là on parle de
la génération artemis aller les gens qui
vont aller sur mars les ingénieurs qui
vont fabriquer ces systèmes l'un des
scientifiques qui vont qui vont élaborer
les grands presque tous ces gens ne sont
ni mais c'est des enfants en ce moment à
des enfants que vous connaissez et c'est
la génération artemis ceux qui vont être
inspiré par thème et artemis qui était
qui est la soeur jumelle la polo
justement parce que on veut qu'il y ait
une femme qui se rendent sur la nuit et
c'est l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
on a pris cette mission leur tennis une
femme et une personne issue de la
diversité
pour
augmenter la pelle motivationnelle si on
veut que le programme spatial à cette
magie de faire ressortir un peu le
meilleur de l'humanité messieurs merci
beaucoup d'avoir été là monsieur la
montagne merci d'avoir été avec nous
pour ce segment est fort intéressant
merci monsieur singer que vous êtes
déplacé en studio on aura assurément
plusieurs émissions de découverte sur le
sujet plusieurs émissions spéciales qui
m'ont veut dire à cet effet vous à
surveiller on espère avoir
bavé j'ai lancé merci à tous d'avoir été
là on va faire une courte pause et
revenir tout de suite après
[Musique]